[Music]
when i fled
california and nussolini's failed state
i didn't i look the weather i miss it
whatever i didn't miss the politics
obviously
didn't miss the homelessness everywhere
but i did miss a few people
i did particularly my friends at prageru
so i've
shipped one of them all the way out here
to nashville
so that we can play the most important
game
at the daily wire the drinking game
where the rules are made up and the
points don't matter
i am joined by my friend will whit
will wit a well-known prageru
personality and the author of the
upcoming book
how to win friends and influence enemies
what a title that is my friend
thank you thank you for being here
michael just brought me out here so he
could have someone to drink with
me that's true i was it was too sad if
you know to skype you in it still feels
like drinking alone you know yeah
so will do you know the rules cause i
don't i don't really know the rules i
watch the one with dave rubin
and everyone's confused the whole time
yeah i think that kind of adds to the
character of the game
it does so broadly speaking i'm gonna
read a prompt then you'll read a prompt
you read the prompt
and you answer as you think the other
person would answer by moving
the other person's drink and then you
just you drink
now before we start speaking in cursive
i should point out that this video is
brought to you by
ring more from ring later for now shall
we get started yes
okay by drinking it
okay i would audition
for the new twilight movie so i'm
answering
you're answering for me
did i get it right you got it right yeah
you obviously yeah of course yeah
i think you've tired out of the politics
i'm done with politics and your skin is
already kind of sparkly
that's true yeah and by the way after
this book tour that i've just had where
i haven't slept for a week i do look
like a vampire i am so yes
so i think we drink fine by me
okay yeah i opted for no ice cubes
that's that's aggressive
yeah you and by the way we should point
out you have appearances to make after
this one
i do but i usually only do my
appearances if i've been drinking it's
true that makes sense
staples the hands out yeah exactly the
shakes to go yeah okay
in 2021 wearing glasses is a choice
yes you're wrong i'm wrong for me you're
wrong okay
yes so i have a chronic eye illness
okay not to get too yeah okay this is
bringing it down making it very personal
okay so
wearing glasses is what i have to do
because if i don't then
my eye is this mucus that starts
producing on my contact it's very gross
but very perfect so i have to i have to
point something out right now
i have a contact and now okay yeah
because you are not wearing glasses
right but i have to wear glasses most of
the other time but i chose because
of this show i said i want to look my
best so you're saying you chose
not to wear glasses yes
i do you know i i should wear glasses
i'm nearsighted so it's
you know i see rachel maddow look is
good on you this was the problem
the i kept getting recognized they'd say
rachel rachel no it was because
yeah i saw your politicon i was doing
this i did i was at the rachel booth
yeah
shapiro actually comes up to me one time
and he goes nulls
uh this is hard for me to say but uh you
gotta lose the glasses
so what do you mean i need to i need the
glasses to see you guys i don't care
conservatives don't wear glasses on tv
i said no that's not true he goes to
name people who wear glasses on tv i
said well you know uh
rachel maddow chris mathis lawrence
o'donnell chris hayes oh this is not
good it's all
it's all the libs that do so i stopped
wearing but now everything's just blurry
yeah when i don't wear my glasses i look
more like ellen degeneres
so ellen degeneres and rachel maddow go
actually pretty well together
all right putting up george floyd
statues
is worse than making juneteenth a
national holiday
i'm going to say yes for you you're
going to say no for me
i'm going to say no for you i think
based on
you i think you would think juneteenth
is a is a waste of time
this is a hard yeah i'm very
anti-juneteenth yes but this is a hard
one
because yeah you know making juneteenth
the new national independence day
is terrible and it's a bunch of broader
but i'm going to have to actually move
this i'm going to have to move because
george floyd was a career criminal
who robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint
and and died
while committing a crime and i i'm not
even saying that that justifies it or i
know now the cop was convicted of murder
even though i think that was a
ridiculous conviction
but there's a way to do juneteenth that
would make it
a good holiday there is no way to put up
a statue of george floyd
right no did i get did i get it right
for you did i think so i mean i
i think well actually i don't know
because i think the significance of
having maybe one statue in some little
town of people
there's already the george floyd square
right and that doesn't affect you know
the entire federal calendar now just by
having a square
so if they put a statue in there too
yeah it would probably be fine but
having the juneteenth holiday and all
the stuff that goes along with that
i mean just as a virtue signal for the
woke left yeah i would say that that's
probably
no yeah you know you make a good
argument because it you don't really get
rid of holidays it's very hard to get
rid of
you can topple statues as the libs have
shown us for a long time now but yeah
that's a good point okay
i shockingly i'm going to remain
indecisive on this
i think we've persuaded one another we
should drink i'm fine with that
the war on drugs did more good than harm
i'm answering for you you are answering
for me
i think we're on the same page well we
guessed in the same way
but i don't know if we're on the same
page here okay explain
i am almost with ann coulter
uh when she says that uh smoking a
doobie should be a capital offense
i'm not quite there but i like the war
on drugs i mean i
the arguments against the war on drugs
are either the libertarian argument that
we should be able to use drugs which i
don't agree with i don't agree with that
either
or the sort of it you know it destroys
families and
in particular the black family which
maybe it does that was the most
convincing to me but you know here's the
answer
stop dealing drugs by the way no one
goes to prison for having a dime bag of
pot
right people plead down from
distribution
deal right these are poison peddlers so
i think that throw them in the can how
about just don't sell drugs you know and
then
we're good i agree like i'm from
colorado and they thought that
legalizing marijuana was going to make
everything better and there wasn't
it's like it got worse there were more
duis and everything because of the drugs
so it's not like it does really any good
you know the other the other thing
is i've i have in my life
experimented with the peruvian parsley
okay i've i've
taken a couple talks of sin spinach all
right uh however
i would say that the people for whom
legalization of pot is the most
important issue
i want i want them to be unhappy i agree
i want i
really enjoy that and so out of a purely
vindictive
spirit i think we got to keep it illegal
i agree
i don't i don't want any of this stuff
lately all right all right we'll put the
yes there
we'll take a little sip does that mean
we drink still yeah sure
well because we can't smile yeah we
can't talk we can't smoke in here
not well not if we keep legalizing
illegalizing but is it legal here in
tennessee or illegal
uh you know i actually
assume it's illegal right it's got to be
illegal here in tennessee yeah what a
good state
yeah so glad i know i'm in los angeles
where you get off the plane and all you
smell is marijuana yeah
as soon as you get off and on the plane
yeah and on the plane too
generally speaking people
generally speaking people you meet on
the street are awful
are these like people i mean my
interviews is that what they're talking
about well i don't know you are a man on
the street kind of guys
okay so they're awful people on the
street
it might be people i mean it might be
people it might be both people that one
meets on the street but also
you know the people the slice of the
people on the street that you talk to
answering for you i'm gonna say
no no any of the people who i talk to
are
great amazing people who just don't know
anything who have never heard
a prageru video or subscribe to the
daily wire anything like that
yeah like they're smart people like the
number one question that i get asked
from people about my videos
is how do you not just laugh at these
idiots and that's that's the wrong thing
to ask because these people are smart
they've just been so brainwashed yeah by
so many different people to think this
way
ignorance is not idiocy right right it's
you gotta you hopefully will correct the
ignorance by telling people
true things but yeah people are
perfectly intelligent and if they've
been completely failed by their
education system
that's that's a cause for pity and the
compassion of sending them a prageru
video or podcast or something like that
don't get me wrong there are awful
people i've i've met some terrible
people
if she takes it as empowering like this
event is and of course i'll call her
you call your daughter a [ __ ] if it was
empowering right exactly
i mean you go out on the street and i'll
meet people who want to kick me off
campus call the police on me
hi um there are two people on our campus
right here four with a
conservative group who are here to try
to fearmonger students
are they threatening you specifically in
any way
not specifically they're threatening me
with their language
with their ideals there are definitely
awful people out there but the vast
majority of people are
brainwashing i agree that's informed
it's a cause of celebration to to take a
drink i think
do we get more or is this it i think you
get more i think yeah i got to catch up
i'm not doing good i'll take another
step sorry
i'll drink slower all right you're up
in america the current protestant
community is doing a better job of
pushing against the progressive takeover
than the catholic community
i'm actually trying to think of what i
think about that myself uh
we used to do at the same time we should
do it at the same time uh
okay all right i'm gonna answer for you
actually wait wait i mean to say yes
you should have kept your first answer
this was a close one
because the evangelicals
for most of the last 50 60 years had
been doing a better job
than most catholics though notably some
of the most important
conservative leaders were catholics i'm
thinking of buckley russell kirk phyllis
schlafly especially
brent bozell like a bunch of bunch of
them but the catholics broadly the
people who identify as catholic like joe
biden who they don't actually believe in
catholicism but they they identify uh
they
you know they kind of gave us all a bad
name whereas the evangelicals were
kind of all on the same page but
recently i find
the evangelicals are getting a little
squishy in some cases
and mainline protestantism just is
progressivism right i mean that that's
why the church is kind of crumbled
i just see the i mean i'll talk to
people in los angeles all the time and
they talk about sending their kids to
catholic school
catholic schools in la southern
california they're not catholic schools
they're not catholic schools at all
they're leftist institutions that say
that they are catholic and then they're
pro-choice
they don't believe in men and women in
the homes or even that a man is a man
yeah yeah no then straight and it's like
maybe there are things within
the leadership of the church that are
still more conservative but you go to
any of these catholic schools they've
totally abandoned the principles there's
a lot it's very hard if you go i mean
depending on the city
if let's say they have 10 catholic
schools maybe you get a couple
that are are really strong on orthodoxy
and you know but it yeah it's it's
it's part of that long march through the
institutions that the left has engaged
in so you know what i will find
when i go to the very liberal catholic
parishes
the median age is like 82. yeah it's all
you know
old people and no kids and then i go to
the really conservative parishes
the median age is like 19 and they all
have 10 kids i don't even know how
biologically that's possible
and they're all the kids are crying but
you know what if it ain't crying it's
dying
it's my view i don't know too much about
catholicism i've never been to a
mass we've got to take you to a good man
a good latin mess i would like to
there's a little
there's a cheat sheet it's a chichi
there's a chichi so you can you know i
don't my latin is not right so
wait you're christian now yeah i got
baptized about four months ago yeah hey
man that's great amazing thing jack
hibbs
this is baptized wow oh tremendous yeah
welcome liberal atheist my whole life
we're gonna have to pull you across the
tiber you know on the camera but they're
all in god's
time that's wonderful that's wonderful
news it is the best day of my life
amazing
thing strength we can drink to that you
know in in moderation
one one can drink our lord's first
miracle as you know
turning water into wine for people who
had been celebrating for
many days right
oh wow pro in providence has perhaps
given us this question
or the producers wrote it they know if
either alcohol or the sin
spinach that's actually the phrase they
use if either alcohol or the sin spinach
were to be banned in america
it would be better to ban the greater
evil alcohol
i kind of gave away my answer
i love drinking i love it it's the best
first thing in the morning no
no no we're drinking a three this is
kind of late for me
people often they make this argument
where they'll be like you know
you know man pots way better for you
than
alcohol it's a plant it's a flying man
it's like yeah
plenty of poisons or plants coca leaf is
a plant it's exactly a lot of tar but
even beyond that
alcohol has been in our culture forever
we just referenced the first miracle of
our lord it goes back and it goes back
much further than that
marijuana is relatively newly introduced
to western civilization
and so i just think well let's say
you're right and alcohol is bad
and certainly in excess why
one why is marijuana better and two if
it's if it's sort of just as bad
or a little bit why would you introduce
this new thing into western civilization
if you think it's so bad
i mean we tried banning alcohol before
and we saw how well that went it did not
so
i don't think it would ever work again
no not at all i agree now hold it right
there before we continue
you know that protecting your home is
extremely important all right i have
1001 reasons to protect my home and all
of them are named cute little june it's
my little baby boy you know i want to
make sure
that when i'm on the road let's say
sweet little elise and cute little june
know who is
outside the door before they open that
door i can have that peace of mind
and i'm very grateful to ring with ring
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door whether you are
upstairs maybe you're at the office
having some drinks early in the morning
with will witt
maybe you are on a beach on the other
side of the world
you can do that with ring it's so simple
to install that even i can do it it's
not just about the
front step by the way you can keep an
eye on every inch of your house it also
makes a great housewarming gift
in no small part because it's just not
that expensive so it's a really great
product and people really want it it
keeps your friends safe but also
you just don't need to spend a ton of
money on it head on over
start protecting your home with ring
alarm today go to ring.com
knowles start building that ring of
security around your home ring.com
knowles you will thank me later
all right let's keep going
since the strongest opposition to
cryptocurrency comes from the chinese
government and democrats
but i repeat myself crypto is most
likely good for the future of this
country
wait yep trying to understand the
question
crypto is most likely good for the
future of this country okay we're
answering on that
put it on the blockchain baby 100 100 do
a social media yeah do it with investors
you know who says this
reagan's favorite economist george
gilder wrote a whole book about this
life after google
says blockchain's the future yes get on
board i know 100
i know i should have i have dreams about
going back in time
and investing in all of these different
things as a 12 year old kid with my 10
dollars
yeah investing in it i know buying apple
stock in 97. i know i know
things we cannot we cannot do over it's
more important to exercise the mind
than it is to exercise the body
okay i now know my answer i'm trying to
think of your answer
i've been working out
i could tell you can tell us shoulder's
getting wider
so i got this right you're telling me
yes or no i don't okay because
i don't know why i think they're both
actually equally important
that's what i'm saying i think that you
need both because if you're a
fat whale but your mind is like that
affects your mind too if you're putting
horrible things into your body yes it
also affects your mind if you're eating
mcdonald's every day that's bad for your
thinking yes
no i well yeah i mean it's it's
delicious but it's probably not great
for your thinking and
and this pro i mean i i say this is
someone who hasn't worked out
you know since the clinton
administration i'll take you to work out
i thought it would be great i want i got
to broaden my shoulders
the thing about it is the the
the human person is actually tripartite
right there's body
and mind and soul or body soul and
spirit rather
i'll say uh so it's important to
discipline your mind it's important to
discipline
your body uh i care very greatly about
spiritual things though i suppose that's
another question
but yeah you gotta like you gotta work
out man it's good to be a chad
maybe i'll you know i'll i'll work on
that song yeah yeah well you get a good
spirit
body and mind with creatine and
pre-workouts yeah
that's how you do it it's in some book
of the bible yeah i assume
yeah nietzsche wrote about in the spoken
sarathustra the ubermensch you know
all about creatine
where's me
dropping out of college because you
disagree with their views
is actually just an excuse to hide the
fact that you could handle it
this one's a personal attack personal
attack
wait a second okay so well no that gives
me a pretty good
a pretty good answer for you but then
you gotta answer for me
yeah i'm gonna say no yeah i think i
think any real conservative person would
say that
you're giving hundreds of thousands of
dollars to an institution that hates
your values
yeah because it's not even it's not even
just like you're leaving because we have
different preferences or something
what i'm saying i actually love liberal
education i'm a big supporter of
not even forget stem i'm talking about
reading poetry and history and stuff
but if you're not getting that if you're
not getting a real liberal education at
a college and you're spending hundreds
of thousands of dollars to do it
get out of there man what are you doing
maybe either transfer to another school
or just
like read books you know and go get a
job i mean that's what i did i mean i
went through two years of school and i
learned almost nothing the only classes
i failed all my classes
except for creative writing creative
writing were the only classes my english
classes because that was something that
i actually enjoyed and wanted to do yeah
but the other classes i mean the
sociology 101
and then the biology even getting into
gender stuff it doesn't make any
biology class where you learn that a man
is a woman yeah the men menstruate
yeah there were live performances on
stage showing us exactly how that is
that's the time to check out yeah uh
europe no i just read that oh that's
right i'm up all right
i gotta catch up yeah
i've never been physically attacked
while asking people questions
for a piece of content
i kind of spoiled this one before
i have been physically attacked yeah
many times
by ex-girlfriends dennis what kind of
content are we talking about yeah
no i did one where i dressed up as a
native american
if you put that in anywhere like you're
dead bro
is that a threat you're just dangering
me because of you there's a there's
an indian i'm not endangering where they
snatched on my headdress we got the
black pilgrim here they snatched it off
this entire class they were stalking us
and they uh ripped off my stuff
it's not your campus it's not your
campus it's a publication it's not your
campus
uh one time speaking at university of
northern colorado black lives matter
came
flipping tables physically trying to
assault the people there
so it happens all the time yeah i i was
only attacked one time on a campus
at the university of missouri the thesis
legitimately was men or not women so
they're all screaming and it's all big
hubbub and then some looney tune busts
in the fire exit behind my podium
and squirts me with i remember this yeah
yeah unknown substance that i'd prefer
not to think about
and uh thankfully he only ruined my
blazer and the cop got him down really
quickly
but who knew i've said i've said
genuinely
outrageous things but that was the most
outrageous
sorry about that michael i've moved on
and i got a new blazer
goes on i can tell good
tactically speaking conservatives should
allow transgender athletes
to compete in male sports because the
inevitable outcome will be the best
weapon to defeat the leftist idea
you mean the abs like the absurdity of
it is is
tactically speaking conservatives should
allow transgender athletes so
basically we should allow them so that
we can get on with it yeah like like
it's wrong
but it'll show how kooky the left is and
that'll red pill a lot of people okay
um
say no no wait it's just wrong yeah it's
just unjust
you don't do something to show how bad
it is
you don't murder someone to say oh
murder is really bad and then show
people
that yeah you don't need to show people
that they should be able to figure this
out with common sense
sometimes people yes and if this is a
bad idea
that conservatives often have and
they'll say this they'll be like you
know
we need to elect a socialist yeah let's
vote for bernie sanders because that'll
show people how bad it is
uh first of all they're not gonna admit
it and second of all
let's avoid you know years and years of
misery and poverty
exactly evil and just not do that but i
mean do you see california
you go to california gavin newsom is
running the state into the ground yeah
and
everyone says it's conservatives fault i
mean you talk to liberals on the street
and they say oh it's because
of the conservatives and the republicans
yeah it's like how brain-dead there are
about four
conservatives left in california i know
it works out pretty well all right
should probably take a drink
oh three drinks to dennis
since the entire democrat apparatus is
pushing against election audits and
voting integrity laws
we can assume with relative certainty
that any election in 2020
was dot dot dot not super legit hold on
this is written here due to youtube
rules
make your guess what the other person
would think but do not
verbally confirm if the other person
guessed correctly
give only an ambiguous nonverbal
confirmation so just to remind you of
what the prompt is yes
because the whole democratic apparatus
push is pushing against election audits
and
also i'll just add changed all the voter
laws and took away all the election
integrity measures just about and in
some cases
violated the state constitution to give
certain groups advantages
in certain political parties advantages
in there
we can say with relative certainty that
any election in 2020 was
just uh not super legit
[Music]
she make your guess but no verbal i
won't confront
someone say anything i think i'm
answering it the right way
just take a drink it's gonna be great
that was the best drink yet we have to
deal with this with prageru all the time
i mean we can't say anything can't well
yeah you can say but you can't say
you know you gotta you can't i mean we
can't even say
we don't do charades anything no that's
horrible pull
three syllables exactly cbd oil there's
a lot of questions about weeds yeah wait
a second what are we saying about mr
whit
you guys hold on i am from colorado yes
it's true
smoking the ganja man cbd oil is more
effective at treating
insert any and all claims than the masks
are at stopping the spread of coven 19.
oh yeah for sure that's not even close
i mean i would i give my dog cbd
doggy cbd he's got social anxiety
so it helps him you know and i think
that that was that's more effective than
the masks
i tried putting a mask on my dog too and
it didn't yeah if it
if it does anything that is either
neutral or positive
it is definitely more effective than the
yeah if it doesn't do anything it's more
helpful okay we're getting down
getting down to the final ones john
mcafee did not kill himself
i think it's a pretty clear pretty clear
answer
yes that dude he sat on his own
tatted it on his arm yeah isn't that
weird though that we're just all like
haha you know
john mcafee obviously was murdered by
his enemies
in prison just like jeffrey epstein
obviously was and we're just like hahaha
you know that's the way it works i am
contemplating getting i did not kill
myself across the forehead
because it's getting to a point where
you can't be true mcafee
actually wrote he said that he was
getting messages from various people and
who know maybe it was just a big troll
but i don't think it was
where he said we're going to kill
yourself
oh man that dude was always kind of a
loose cannon he was she was crazy dude
but i don't think killed himself no no
way
all right here we go i like this one
[Laughter]
the producers know me very well man on
the man on the street journalism is
similar
to being a model on instagram
uh you know what
listen me being attractive helps the
views for the man on the street okay
me having great hair makes people want
to talk to me yeah
yeah no i yes like i'm not i'm not just
disputing that and also
being an instagram model is often fairly
lucrative like it's like a it's a very
effective way of communicating yes
if i was born hot with double d's and a
woman i would be a billionaire i mean
the things you can do on instagram these
days these days
you could well claim to have been born
hot with double d's
and a woman yeah don't don't uh
stereotype me okay
don't assume yeah don't assume don't
assume or underneath this
let's check before before you show me i
suppose we should we'll show i'll take
it right yeah
behind the scenes